also ihr seht das ja gerade das ist
jetzt ungefähr eine halbe minute ja dass
ich denke da rein getan habe irgendwann
mache ich auch mal eine eigene marke die
hatten einfach nein
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja halt ich hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt gut ich weiß nicht
ob man es hört meiner stimme geht es
nicht so gut ich war die letzten zwei
drei tage echt erkältet gestern bin ich
mir gar nicht gut heute geht es mir
irgendwie schon wieder viel besser und
deswegen drehe ich habe mich heute auf
dieses video was schon ein bisschen
länger geplant war ich habe nämlich
letzten sieben folgende nachricht
bekommen für alexander öfter so es ist
wie du es machst habe ich mir gedacht
das würde ja eigentlich ziemlich gut zu
dir passen schau dir das mal an haben
auch schon ein paar amerikanische
youtuber gemacht aber würde bestimmt gut
zu dir passen also das war mir
geschrieben ich habe mich darüber mal
ein bisschen informiert und zwar ist das
ein trend der stammt von seiner website
und da geht es halt darum dass man mit
bestimmten methoden herausfinden kann ob
zb dieser käse hier wirklich komplett
aus käse besteht oder ob da irgendwelche
zusatzstoffe mit drin sind ob dieser
kaffee oder drei euro günstiger ist als
dieser kaffee keine zusatzstoffe enthält
und so weiter wie gesagt ich habe schon
zwei drei videos in anderen sprachen
gesehen wo halt diese sachen getestet
wurden also muss ich auch hier ganz
offen und ehrlich sagen das ist jetzt
nicht meine idee wobei die idee ja auch
irgendwie von der website kommt und ich
habe mir gedacht komm doch einfach mal
sachen die du ab und zu benutzt und
testet sie auf diese methoden ich will
eigentlich auch gar nicht eingeladen ich
kann aber auch nicht sagen das ist zu
hundert prozent klappt ich habe keinen
plan ich bin euch die fotos von der
website ein und bei manchen sachen steht
halt auch dass es noch nicht belegt ist
dass es wirklich so ist also die haben
das wohl auch an ein wissenschaftliches
institut gesendet und manche sachen
haben sich wohl auch als falsch
herausgestellt ich habe allerdings nur
sachen gekauft die belegt sind oder die
noch nicht getestet wurden und ich würde
sagen wir fangen wir an mit kaffee dazu
brauchen wir einmal diese beiden gläser
wasser und ich habe euch ja schon hier
den kaffee gezeigt ich war gut einkaufen
habe einmal teuren dallmayr kaffee kauft
für 7 euro
und dann noch in diesem café von der
marke ja ich könnte ja wahrscheinlich
jeder von euch irgendwie immer wenn ich
diese marke sehe ich das total mit sich
dass nun mal einfach so jahr heißt passt
jetzt nicht zum thema auf jeden fall bin
ich erstmal gespannt ich zeig euch immer
das foto worum es gehen soll
und zwar steht oben drüber auf englisch
ich übersetze frühestens deutsche kaffee
mit zusatzstoffen schwimmt purer café
sinkt also man kann das ja auch sehen
bett und gehört und ich würde jetzt
einfach mal vom preis aussehen und sagen
das hier eventuell ein paar zusatzstoffe
drin sind und hier gegebenenfalls nicht
ob das so stimmt kein plan für den vista
und hast du ganz wichtig wenn ihr sagt
alex macht auf jeden fall part 2 dann
lass nach oben da ihr freund war khedira
auch schneller so ich muss kurz in
doppelrollen okay ich würde sagen wir
fangen wir mit dem teuer im café an
also ich bin wirklich gespannt laut dem
test müsste dieser kaffee jetzt ganz
normal sinken
[Musik]
ich würde mal sagen das ist ganz wichtig
dass man ein bisschen abwartet weil das
meiste vom café ist noch gar nicht mit
wasser in verbindung mit kommt okay aber
wenn ihr jetzt hier mal schaut man sieht
halt ganz klar der kaffee sinkt komplett
weiß sich besonders schnell
aber das ganze wasser ist halb voll mit
kaffee okay das hätten wir schon mal und
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was hier
passiert dieser kaffee hat nicht mal die
hälfte gekostet ich weiß nicht wieso
aber ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich
sicher es handelt sich bei beiden parken
500 gramm bekommen es allerdings sofort
dass dieser irgendwie viel leichter ist
als der keine ahnung und er löst sich
halt direkt im also der ist nicht so
fest zusammengepresst wird ob das
irgendwas damit zu tun hat weiß ich
nicht kann natürlich auch sein dass der
jetzt sinken wird wenn er allerdings
zusatzstoffe enthält müsste er schwimmen
ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
also ihr seht das ja gerade das ist
jetzt ungefähr eine halbe minute her
dass ich den kaffee da rein getan habe
ich bin mir aber jetzt schon zu 100
prozent sicher dass der prozess vom
sinken
bei diesem teuren kaffee auf jeden fall
deutlich schneller ging klar hier sind
auch was aber ihr seht ja also das ist
nicht besonders viel das meiste stimmt
halt wirklich oben drauf find ich schon
wirklich interessant ich würde sagen ich
stelle die beiden sache jetzt erst mal
zur seite und wir schauen dass das dann
gleich nochmal was ihr aber auch noch
auffällt diese kleinen partikel die
daher sinken also diese café partikel
sind deutlich größer als die hier da
würde ich sagen wir machen weiter haben
einem test den wir ganz schnell mal eben
dazwischen schieben können und zwar den
hier
ok eigentlich kann man sich das auch
sparen finde ich weil hier geht es jetzt
um fakes aber wer in deutschland genutzt
fakes das habe ich noch nie gehört weil
das ist jetzt kein knappes lebensmittel
so oder ich hab so glaube ich auch nur
teures salz deswegen würde ich sagen wir
kippen dass hier mal rein oder was heißt
eures haushalt sei es was ich denke mal
kein fake salz ist wir werden es
ausprobiert das ist auch aus dem
supermarkt das wasser darf sie jetzt
halt nicht so denn wie soll ich sagen
nebelig oder wolkig färben kann man das
hier sagen kann so vielleicht sogar ein
bisschen was aus aber also ich würde das
jetzt mal nicht als wolkig bezeichnen
aber ich muss sagen dass enel sich jetzt
schon ziemlich mit der photo schreibt
gerne über eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare
ich würde mal sagen dass ich das jetzt
mache ich würde mich wirklich sehr
darüber wundern wenn das jetzt schlecht
ist als das ist okay leute dann kommen
wir jetzt zu den tests auf die ich mich
am meisten freue weil es zum feuer geht
ja und da bin ich auch wirklich gespannt
ich würde sagen so der hauptquest heute
ist auf jeden fall käse machen wir dann
aber wir starten einfach mal mit paprika
gerührt und zwar haben wir hier paprika
edelsüß für drei euro 79 und hier
paprika von unserer lieblingsmarke nein
irgendwann mache ich auch mal so eine
eigene marke die heißen einfach nein
also dass hier 59 cent gekostet dass
hier fast achtmal so viel und es ist
fast die gleiche füllmenge hier ist ein
ganz bisschen mehr drin aber der
preisunterschied es trotzdem riesig
deswegen gehe ich mal davon aus dass sie
das hier ja zusatzstoffe enthält bzw
kein pures paprika gewürzt ist hier seht
ihr mal kurz das foto das steht hier
oben drüber
pures gewürz brennt und zergeht begleit
fest dass ca
dass nichts mehr geht es heißt entzündet
also es brennt und entzündet sich und
gemischtes gewürz halt nicht also das
müsste heißen wenn ich das jetzt hier
auf den löffel tor das anzünden passiert
rein gar nichts
und ob dann wirklich das teure gewürz
brands wir werden sehen ich will
natürlich jetzt auch nicht mehr ins
zimmer abfackeln
so was kommt ja erst mal ein bisschen
was drauf also hier haben wir das billig
gewürzt ich ziehe jetzt einfach mal an
welcher mensch hat in seinem leben schon
gewiss angezündet und genau jetzt ist
die boogie aufnahme abgebrochen also ihr
könnt schon sehen was immer kommt halt
wirklich jetzt muss ich gleich erstmal
luft
das ist ja richtig ab damit leute jetzt
muss ich erstmal hier kurz löschen
mein ganzes zimmer stinkt okay jetzt
stellt sich nur die frage
das hat auf jeden fall oder es hat sich
entzündet man hat das ganz klar gesehen
ich weiß nicht ob man es auf der kamera
so gut sieht aber ich habe es ganz klar
gesehen könnt ihr mir glauben und jetzt
haben wir hier noch das teurere gebühr
als ich sehe auf jeden fall schon im
klaren unterschied das ist irgendwie
viel heller ja noch langsamer so das
sollte auch schon reichen also hier
haben wir das teure gewürz ich zünde es
jetzt einfach mal an mal gucken was
passiert ich bin selber gespannt
[Musik]
also ich muss sagen es kommt natürlich
eigentlich genauso stark aber ich habe
hier keine flamme darauf gesehen also
bei dem anderen habe ich halt gesehen
dass ich das wirklich rentiert hat also
das ist dann jetzt leider aber ich muss
schon wieder löschen und wo es zu diesen
kästchen ein kleiner nachtrag ich habe
das irgendwie ein bisschen durcheinander
gebracht im endeffekt hat das billige
gewürz und das teure geburt haben beide
gebrannt laut dem test vorgaben war es
ja so dass das günstige gebührt nicht
brennen darf weil halt zusatzstoffe drin
sind halt meiner meinung nach auch
gequalmt und gebrannt von daher kann man
sagen anscheinend waren beide gewürze
vollkommen in orten oder der test ist
ein mal für ne sch keine ahnung wie auf
dem foto ist es halt so dass die kerze
einfach unter dem löffel ist aber das
habe ich auch versucht bis ich da
irgendwas tut das dauert ewig ich muss
jetzt erst mal lüften und dann machen
wir weiter mit dem käse denn zünden wir
nämlich auch an leute ihr glaubt nicht
wie verbrannt ist in diesem zimmer
richters aetka soll bis zum nächsten
test auf dem freue ich mich eigentlich
am meisten
ich bin ein richtiger käse ferner sich
also super gerne käse ich habe drei
verschiedene arten wo wir haben ja einer
kerrygold ich nenne es jetzt mal marken
krise für zwei euro 30 dieser hat ein
euro drei cent kostet und dieser hier
der soweit ich weiss komplett
vollgepumpt mit chemikalien deshalb
schmelzkäse kostet nicht mal ein euro
ihr blende ich euch jetzt einmal das
foto einen da seht ihr ja einmal käse
der halt spaß wird wenn man mit dem
fahrzeug drang und der naturelle käse
der halt so bley also käse wurst käse
mit irgendwelchen chemikalien drin was
auch immer ich würde sagen wir fangen
einfach mal hier mit dem kerrygold an
ja das ist der teuerste ich gehe mal
davon aus dass hier nicht so viel
passiert also wenn der sich schwarz
gehabt würde mich wundern
[Musik]
kummer klar der wird ein bisschen
schwarz weil er an brennt aber er krümmt
sich jetzt nicht so schnell ein also
schmilzt hat er das kann man ganz klar
sehen man hat auf jeden fall eine
reaktion wir schauen jetzt mal ob die
bei den anderen beiden käsesorten kasse
aus dass jemand durch man muss ja nicht
alles verbindungen also das ist die
billigere variante für 130 oder so bin
ich mal gespannt ob wieder andere aktion
haben wir gesagt
[Musik]
also hier muss ich sagen die reaktion
ist noch geringer als bei dem hier man
kann es ja ganz klar sehen was jemand
muss jedes also hier sieht man ja
schwarze stelle und was hier mit
passiert ist wenn wir jetzt aber mal
nach den testergebnissen gehen scheint
was weil sind nicht vernünftige
käsesorten zu sein also könnt ihr
anscheinend guten gewissens essen dann
haben wir jetzt in sandwich käse und
hier bin ich jetzt richtig mal gespannt
also sage ich davon aus dass er direkt
spaß wird ich finde man ließ auch schon
extrem an der farbe dass das kein
naturelle käse ist ist natürlich auch
schmelzkäse aber manchmal heißt mein
falls man mal schauen was passiert
[Musik]
hier muss man ganz klar sagen der
schmilzt nicht so wie diese hier sondern
der wunsch war also laut dem test ist
das hier auf jeden fall kein naturelle
käse werde ich auch vorher eigentlich
schon beantworten können schmeckt aber
trotzdem gut zumindest auf dem sandwich
ich will das jetzt noch mal kurz zum
vergleich haben mich halt hier nochmal
das feuerzeug dran aber das ist halt
wirklich ganz klar so also der wird
nicht so schwer also meiner meinung nach
wirklich interessant muss man auch erst
mal auf die idee kommen das so zu
testenden habe ich eigentlich noch
da geht es um butter da würde ich aber
sagen das nehmen wir dann im nächsten
part mit rein weil sonst wird das video
schon wieder viel zu lange ich habe
schon das gefühl hat geht wahrscheinlich
schon über 15 minuten ich weiß nicht
genau also wenn ihr bock aber auch paar
zwei lassen wir nach oben darstellt sind
die kommentare jacket instagram ab 30
alexia boni nicht vergessen glock hat
demnächst dazu verpassen
und wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder haut
rein